hello everyone and welcome to a very
interesting game from round two of the
2018 United States Championship that
features yet another line of the
venerable variation of the French and
it's not like I'm choosing to show only
whenever French these days though we had
a bunch of verses Kasparov and then we
had Lille a chest 0 vs. am lawless but
it seems like all the best games are now
played in that variation here we have a
game between world chess championship
challenger Fabiano Caruana and his
countryman Alexandra Linderman so like I
said a very exciting game and a lot of
you have suggested it so obviously I had
no choice but to show it and I don't
have any any photos per se but I do have
this one from the stream so here just to
get that to get in the mood for the game
it's for a really poor quality to show
it fullscreen so I'm afraid this will
have to do for now so let's see the game
Fabi has the white pieces and he opens
with E 4 we have e 6 the Ferengi defense
d4 d5 Knight to c3 and Bishop to b4 as
we've said the whenever variation of the
French we have E 5 the advanced c5 now
comes a3 Bishop captures pawn captures
and now Queen to a5 kind of attacking
that opponent c3 but it's it would be a
very rare variation where black would
actually capture this pawn with the
Queen in the game Fabi continued Bishop
to d2 but if you're playing maybe
against a friend somewhere or it's maybe
a casual game or something you can you
can try to trick him with Knight to f3
and you know if he thinks maybe you
blundered or something maybe he actually
grabs this and it's not not immediately
clear how does how does the white punish
this but if you know then maybe you can
grab a couple of sneaky points with this
for example a Bishop to b2 you're
attacking the Queen Queen to be 2 you
have to move the Queen it's the only
square now Row 2 b1
you attack the Queen Queen captures on
a3 and now rook to b3 and now it finally
becomes apparent that if you play Queen
to a4 Bishop to b5 we'll check the King
and when the Queen
but the the interesting part is that
what if you play queen - a - if going to
a 2 and then queen the c1 and it doesn't
matter what black plays next comes rook
to a3 and the queen is trapped
regardless of worldwide plays and again
if you move back here then again Bishop
to b5 will be check and the game is lost
for black but okay either way after
Queen to a5 the reason why Knight to f3
is not play because black doesn't have
to capture why can simply capture on d4
but okay
Bishop to d2 by Fabi and now Queen to a4
kind of forcing the White Queen - stay
on b1 as the c2 point is now attacked
and also pressuring the d4 pawn now
probably plays Queen to g4 at totally
disregarding this c2 pawn and you might
you might think why not why not grab the
c2 point well the g7 point is attacked
first you have to take care of this King
to f8 you could play g6 yes but this
would only weaken the dark squares
around your King you already gave up
your dark square bishop so no no good
reason to do this
so King to f8 and now comes h4 Fabi
doesn't care about the squint captures
and C to move h4 is an excellent move
black is definitely having ideas of 97
to g6 maybe then h5 will always be an
idea to keep this night away this also
opens up a nice square for this rook so
a nice rook lift will be in order
Rho can come to h3 than G tree or maybe
f3 if needed also will help out with the
defense of the of the C 3 Square and if
black even decides to play something
like Queen captures on c2 which ideas of
maybe rook to c1 attacking the Queen and
bringing the Queen over to Jesus to g6
kind of snatching the pawn and then
going for the Queen exchange you could
you could go Queen to h3 and then maybe
but Queen will be somewhat under under a
lot of attack here after Bishop to d3
and as always this rook and c1 is
x-raying that Bishop unsee it very
nicely
and another thing after work to see one
you could exchange Queens immediately
with Queen to b4 check button after
Queen captures pawn
actors and let's say f3 and night
captures captures again white would have
this excellent center and he would have
a very clear way of developing his
pieces can come to c4 to b5 and again
all of black's pieces are undeveloped on
the last rank so probably both of them
as they are playing this variation
obviously have a lot of lines prepared
Knight to c6 he doesn't really care
about the c2 pawn
obviously if the world chess
championship challenger offers it you do
not want to grab it
h5 by Fabi and here again what do you
play here obviously you don't want to go
for the C to pawn again there's no point
in repeating the variation just showing
the knight c6 move didn't change it but
it's interesting what if you go Knight
pawn captures on d4 as you are attacking
the d4 point three times now well then
h6 begins an all-out attack on the black
King now you do have to react to this
obviously G captures and now Bishop to
d3 and now we see we have an open line
for the rook this bishop is very strong
this bishop is very strong the Queen is
very active when g4 and after something
like Knight captures in Queen to f4 it's
a very it's a very interesting position
captures would check you have to capture
and now Queen to d6 is a very serious
threat after we defend this then C
captures Bishop to b4 it's coming and
now the black King will feel very very
uncomfortable on a fake and like still
has this problem of every piece being
undeveloped so a Lenderman isn't
interested in this he plays h6 stopping
all ideas Fabi head of pushing h6
himself Queen back to d1 and now C
captures on d4 very very instructive how
Fabi handles this position there's no
point in recapturing on d4 black would
simply recapture back so nice to f3 pawn
captures on c3 Bishop captures on c3
now the five point is guarded twice and
here g5 was played g5 but it's very hard
to find a move here for black for
example if Evangel was playing this
position with black he would he will
definitely play Knights to be eight
nice to be eight is a move you you could
maybe find it if you if you spend like
like a lot of time trying to decipher
the position it's it's the engine stop
recommended move Knight to b8 and as
Evangel always says the hardest move to
find is with Knight back simply because
it opens up opens up this diagonal for
your Queen to return into the defense
so after let's say Russia before check
night defence and night to d4 you can
now come back with the Queen and now
black will regroup unpin with King to g8
the knight is now coming back to c6
exchange some pieces and this is one way
for black black to handle this position
but you know it's very hard to decide
for a move like this getting the knight
back
so after this h6 queen d1 and pawn
captures as we've said g5 was played so
H captors and g6 on pass on Queen to b4
checked Bishop to e2 blocking and now
Queen captures on g6 and here Foley
played Queen to d2 and the far we spent
far we spent a lot of time I believe
it's around 23 minutes deciding on this
move as you don't have to figure out is
is this okay to give up the G to pawn
and what to do next figure out an entire
game plan and of course you don't really
achieve anything by grabbing the spawn
simply rook to g1 I mean there's no
reason to do this so Knight to G to e7
simply developing and now we have Bishop
to d3 Fabi attacks the Queen and this
was the idea one of the ideas of the
Queen to d2 move and now what do you do
with the Queen well you could simply
play it back wing to g7 which would be
the best word for the Queen but here
after spending almost 10 minutes I
believe it's 9 minutes and 10 seconds
Queen captures on g2 was played
Aleksandra lunderman doesn't find
anything wrong with this as of course
rook to g1 is isn't really an idea
immediately because the knight is also
under attack now the bishop is no longer
I need to to defend the knight and the
first time I saw a theme like this was
in a game of Alexandra
it was in a game where his opponent
captured the b7 pawn attacked the rook
here and the knight on c6 and then a
lien played King from e8 to d7 and
defended the night with his King and so
did Fabi playing this game he played
King - E - now he defended the night
with the King and now this rook can also
come here - it took it to attack the
Queen and also trap the Queen so the
Queen must move Queen to g4 was played
and now comes rock to h4 not allowing
the Queen any escape via maybe maybe
this way so the Queen now has to go back
further quick Queen to g7 and now comes
rock to g1 so the Queen doesn't really
have anywhere to go you have to you have
to block this with Knight to g6 which
was played in the game and now comes
rope to f4 so unfortunately for
Alexandra Linderman for the price of one
pawn he now has a whole lot of problems
this rooks are immensely active the
bishops are I mean excellent this
whenever this Knight moves Bishop to b4
will be a deadly move rook captures and
g6 is an immediate threat as the f7 pawn
is pinned so here King to e7 is the best
way to continue from black you have to
unpin as soon as possible but here
Alexander Linderman was in serious time
trouble as all of the moves from this
position forward were played in in a
couple of seconds here at Lanterman
plays Knight seat the e7 simply
defending the knight on g6 but here's
the problem
he now moved the knight from c6 and is
no longer controlling the be for square
and Fabi immediately punishes this
Bishop to b4 and now there is no defense
against rook captures and g6 Lenderman
played a5 this was played in five
seconds and Fabi played captures on g6
and it was in this position that
Alexander Lenderman resigned to the game
there is no move here black can play the
Queen he has nowhere to go on only
squares Queen to h7 and now you can play
basically any move you still win the
game but simply Bishop captures with
chair King captures an hour up to g1 and
now the Queen a really is trapped
with not a single square available for
her if you play a 5e characters on f6 on
Poisson would check again you lose the
Queen but it's interesting even without
this a5 move which was played in time
trouble even if you play something like
King e8 unpinning
then again it's a very simple Bishop
captures the knight is pinned you can't
capture and after King captures now
Queen to b4 check King moves now Queen
d6 check Bishop to Bishop blocks and now
Bishop to b5 there is no way there is no
any good way to stop checkmate here you
have to play a 5 and then simply rook
captures again you can't capture the
rook because you lose it Squinkie after
some b7 checkmate and after you play
something like Queen d7 doesn't really
matter simply captures captures and
check King knows and you pick up the
final piece and after all of this is
said and done you're up two pieces and
that's simply too much material to even
consider playing this so after this rook
captures and G six o'clock central
Enderman resigned the game so yeah a
brilliant victory and the brilliant
miniature this is 23 moves with the
white pieces against the win over French
very nice and a very instructive game if
you face a lot of French defense you
know you might you might want to check
this out to end and perhaps you even
enjoyed it so yeah now here we can check
out this photo one last time here is his
second movement playing it and yeah it's
still too early in the tournament this
is only the second round so I will not
be showing any results or pairings but
as the tournament progresses I'm sure I
will show maybe maybe even get a couple
of photos so that's it I will say that
for now in the lead which two points is
Wesley so I believe tied with also
another player I didn't really check it
out that thoroughly but like I said as
the tournament progresses I will give it
give it more attention and I would like
to thank all of our guy and see Muhammad
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon hopefully with another
interesting video and
one question for all of you I do see a
lot of comments on my videos that the
audio on my videos has decreased so does
this have any merit to it you know do
share in the comments thank you all and
I will see you soon